So ziemlich jeden Tag gegen halb drei macht
sich Thekla Schünemann auf den Weg.
Wo geht’s denn jetzt hin?
Und dann?
Sie holt ihren Freund Lars Nowak ab.
Thekla und Lars sind Mitte 50 und leben in
einer Wohneinrichtung der „Lebenshilfe“,
einem Selbsthilfeverband für
Menschen mit geistiger Behinderung.
Insgesamt rund hundert
Menschen wohnen hier –
in WGs mit bis zu sieben Personen.
Manche brauchen mehr,
manche weniger Hilfe.
Für alle Fälle sind rund um die Uhr
Betreuer in den vier Häusern.
Dass Thekla und Lars als Paar leben dürfen,
wäre anderswo unmöglich.
Hier ist das kein Problem – es ist einfach so.
Ihr kennt euch schon so lange,
da wart ihr noch Kinder?
Ein Liebespaar mit Down-Syndrom.
Zum Alltag in der Wohneinrichtung
gehören ganz selbstverständlich
die Beziehungen mit dazu.
Die Hausleitung hat Vertrauen.
Die Bewohner sollen selbst bestimmen und
entscheiden, was sie wollen und was nicht.
Jeder Mensch wünscht sich Beziehungen,
jeder Mensch wünscht sich Nähe.
Das steckt, glaub ich –
egal ob Menschen mit Behinderungen oder
ohne Behinderungen –,
in jedem Menschen drin.
Konstantin Kluß ist oft langweilig.
Er ist 32 und sehnt sich nach einer Partnerin.
Als er zehn war, fuhr ihn ein Auto an.
Seitdem ist er behindert, wie er sagt.
Pädagogin Marie hilft ihm,
wenn er auf einem Dating-Portal
für Menschen mit Beeinträchtigungen
nach einer Freundin sucht.
Ja, ich will auch Sex mit der.
Und das ist ja human, also menschlich.
Penis!
Penis? Gut, dann würde ich heute gerne mit
euch über Geschlechtsteile sprechen,
und zwar von Mann und Frau.
Hier trifft sich die Sex-und-Liebe-Gruppe.
Jede Frage ist erlaubt:
Wie masturbiert man eigentlich richtig?,
zum Beispiel.
Die Gruppe ist eines der beliebtesten
Angebote der Wohneinrichtung.
So sieht der Penis aus.
Hast du das schon mal so gesehen?
Auch in echt?
Ja.
Hast du schon mal … ja, oder?
Thekla und Lars fahren regelmäßig
zusammen in den Urlaub –
und da haben sie auch schon
gemeinsam übernachtet.
Wichtig ist der Lebenshilfe, dass alles
einvernehmlich und respektvoll passiert.
Jeder Mensch darf schlafen, wo er möchte.
Wenn dann die gastgebende Partei
sozusagen einverstanden ist.
Und miteinander schlafen ist was,
was wir nicht in einem Büro oder in einem
Gruppenraum verhandeln,
sondern das verhandelt ihr untereinander.
Davon profitiert die 60-jährige Sabine
Hülfenhaus, die in der Wohneinrichtung lebt,
und ihr gleichaltriger Partner Helmut
Hermann.
Geht’s noch?
Ja.
Zusammen genießen sie das Leben –
heute im Zoo in Hannover.
Sabine hat früher darüber nachgedacht,
selbst Kinder zu haben, als sie jung war.
Aber sie bekam immer wieder gesagt, das
ginge nicht.
Ich bin behindert. Dann kann ich’s nicht.
Umso wichtiger ist für Sabine,
dass sie Helmut hat.
Und die Lebenshilfe ihr die Möglichkeit
zu Nähe und Liebe gibt.